los ministros de finanzas de la Unión
Europea han dado un primer visto bueno a
un nuevo paquete de ayuda a Ucrania de
18.000 millones de euros ya para el
próximo año la idea de la comisión
europea es que el primer desembolso
pueda ser el próximo en el oeste paquete
de ayuda financiera consistirá sobre
todo en préstamos a largo plazo
flexibles y sin intereses y en los que
estarán incluidos los 3.000 millones de
euros comprometidos hasta ahora también
por la Unión Europea y que aún no se han
desembolsado la comisión europea hará su
propuesta formal de este nuevo paquete
de ayuda mañana mismo este nuevo paquete
sobre todo lo que incluirá es intentar
ayudar en todos los gastos mensuales que
tiene Ucrania de aproximadamente 4.000
millones de euros al mes esta no ha sido
la única cuestión que han discutido los
ministros de finanzas porque han
mostrado su enorme preocupación por la
ley de reducción de la inflación
estadounidense una norma que entre otras
cuestiones da ayudas a Fiscales a los
que compren automóviles eléctricos
fabricados en Estados Unidos para la
Unión Europea esta nueva ley podría
contravenir las leyes internacionales de
comercio de momento se ha creado un
grupo de trabajo entre Estados Unidos en
la Unión Europea para encontrar una
solución Aunque Francia cree que la
comisión europea debería llevar el caso
ante la Organización Mundial del
Comercio si no hay ningún avance aún así
Bruselas se muestra dispuesta a
encontrar una solución y una de ellas
podría ser que los automóviles europeos
también estén exentos de esta ley igual
que ya lo están los de México y Cana